Another example here mosaicing.
Now we've talked about mosaicing before.
We talked about panoramas about aligning
images and bringing them together.
Well instead of just a small
discreet set of images,
suppose you actually have a video.
So you're taking your camera and
you're panning it around.
What you might want to do
is make a single image.
Okay?
And this comes from
Michael Irani's work.
Of where you can see
where all the frames are.
Okay you can sort of see these,
this jagged line,
each one being the edge of a frame.
And you realize what happened is the,
the camera was swept out this way.
All right, and
I'm able to make this single image.
All right, and If I'm rotating
my camera about its axis,
I'm not actually doing any translating.
The reconstruction can be
perfect because I don't have any
motion parallax.
And if these things are planes
I have to align some points.
How many points does it take?
It's a homography question.
That's right,
even Megan got four points for that.
And in fact, if I am moving, but
things are really on a plane,
it's still, four points.
So there are other applications
of motion analysis.
You know,
segmenting objects in space or time.
Sometimes you can get
the 3-dimensional structure
if you know how the points are moving,
you know which point is which.
Just like when you saw the person.
You might want to learn the dynamics
of how some things move.
Maybe you're doing, physiology.
And you're watching people moving, and
you want to understand something about
their gait, and
the dynamics of their gait.
All right?
Recognizing events and activities.
You'd like to be able to say,
what just happened in the video?
So it's not just object recognition,
it's action recognition.
And finally, you might just
want to process the video and
understand the motion
to improve the quality.
So you might do motion stabilization,
right, so that you've
got this jerky camera and you'd like
to get a nice smooth video out.
There are simple ways of doing that and
complicated ways.
In fact,
a colleague of mine here Irfanisa and
a former, student of mine Veroquatra and
some others did some work on
stabilizing video especially when you
have rolling shutters in cell phones.
Anyway, these are all reasons for
wanting to process motion.